um I don't have much of a routine I'm
I'm a slightly disorganized person I I
tend to resist routine it's been a while
since I've worked on a novel when I did
and let's say I wasn't having you know I
often had to teach no matter what but
luckily most of my teaching would take
place at night so you know it was mess
around in the morning drink coffee read
the newspaper come back it's always
mostly most of my writing career has
been during the era of email you know do
email waste time and then you know start
looking over what you'd done the day
before to feel a little bit less afraid
and then work for a few hours with
breaks and lying down now most of the
writing I do whether it be from
magazines or you know or for the TV show
is on deadlines and so you know maybe I
have two days to write a script or I
have a day or three days you know and so
then somewhat similar routine get up
drink coffee read the paper but sit down
and having a deadline can work and then
you just write - you can't write anymore
and you take breaks and you know
well yes I I there there are two dual
things when you when I sketch out a
story is not unlike writing because
sometimes I would write it out a bit
more than the headlines you know but and
that would be my way to start
formulating those things that onstage
then I would just verbally kind of
improv my description of what someone
looked like or what a moment felt like
so in some ways the initial crafting of
the story is the same though I do much
less performing of new material now I
tend to just do all my old material and
on most of my creative impulse goes into
writing but actually performing and
writing are two very different things
and I'm glad that I've had both in my
life because performing at night was
very athletic and ephemeral I also could
meet people afterwards it was social you
know is the opposite of the writers life
and yes you're responding you see
someone something comes to you in the
moment you know but then it's gone you
know even if it's recorded it was note
it's never quite the same you know and
you can't see the audience you can't
feel everything so I liked it for it
just being like I'm just like I said
athletic and almost like nature you know
oh the light was beautiful that day but
it's gone oh the performance was great
that night but it's gone whereas writing
is your alone and it's very much about
the sentence and you're responding to
other writers and books and you're
trying to you're trying to do something
in a sentence you know you're trying to
make beautiful sentences as well as move
people along and keep them interested so
that that it's a much more you know
craft it's for me the writing is about
the craft how can I write a beautiful
and concise sentence that gives pleasure
and entertains
you